oh and let me just say don't get so
caught up on the word
mentor you don't need to ask hey can you
be my mentor you don't need
that don't get so caught up on the ward
and get
more focused on the relationship hello
everybody my name is nyan i'm the black
female engineer i provide content for
new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about how to find
a mentor specifically finding a mentor
in the tech realm now if you're looking
to
let this be a very quick process and a
one week process of finding a mentor
this video is not for you
because finding a mentor and cultivating
that relationship takes
months months and months and months
because that is really how you will get
the most out of the
relationship so let's get to it the
first thing you want to make sure you're
doing
is being active in the deaf community
this could be from slack channels
facebook groups twitter make sure you're
being active in the deaf
community as a whole if where you are
they're providing meetups of some kind
and you feel safe
to do it go to those meetups i know it
can be very scary
to go somewhere where you know nobody
believe me believe me i am not
it's it's hard but it can really be what
sets you up for success
in trying to find a mentor and honestly
also a job but that's
a conversation for a different day and
can really be what sets you up for
success
for creating and cultivating these
amazing
relationships linkedin and facebook are
also great places to try to find a
mentor
facebook i really like facebook for this
facebook you could literally just go in
the search bar and type up
women in tech or minorities in tech or
underrepresented groups and
all of that and you will find all of
these different groups now just because
that group shows
up doesn't mean that they're the right
one for you to see if they're the right
one for you
i highly recommend just clicking on it
and going through
the different communications and the
different posts throughout
the like at least a few weeks because
then you can see how active the members
of that group
are and you see the way they communicate
are they very formal with each other
is it more laid back is it really more
spammy
and you really won't get something out
of it go through that research because
we want to make sure you find
exactly what you're looking for another
route you can go
is going on linkedin and looking up
people
in the profession that you want to be or
in the company that you want to be in so
you can search
google or something like that and let's
say you live in austin so google in
austin
and see who pops up and when you see
someone who has the same background as
you then i say message them message them
and say hey
my name is nya i really would like to
connect with you and find
out a little bit more about your story i
am new into coding development
and i would love to hear about what got
you here
because i am a black woman i would
always look
for black women to pop up on the
linkedin search
and i would also say that i would say
especially being a black woman in tech
i would love to hear about your
experience if you're free i would love
to do a 20-30 minute call
honestly just ask and do this with a
couple of people because sometimes
people don't check their linkedin
sometimes people
don't want to talk to you and that's
okay that's okay
but try to message a few of these people
at least
five of these people and be on calls
with them actually
try to talk with them on the phone and
ask them how they got here
ask them about their story tell them
about yourself your goals
and end it with one asking for advice
and also
asking if you could keep up
communication with them this is going to
be the first step into building that
mentor-mentee relationship
and so asking if you can maintain
communication really just
helps open the door a little bit more
for that relationship to
happen and also ask them what groups
they suggest you join
what slack channels or facebook groups
etc they suggest you
join because then at least you have
someone vouching for a certain group
and you can kind of go into it a little
bit with less hesitation
and there's just so much out there y'all
it's it
it's so hard to keep up with so just
asking people directly
what groups they suggest can really
really help with
finding that right group for me i made
sure to join a couple of different
groups
that aligned with different parts of my
identity so for example me
i'm a black woman in tech so the
three groups i would recommend looking
for is
one that catered to women in tech one
that catered to black people in tech and
one that catered to
black women in tech and so that is
really what i mean by catering the
groups
or finding groups that catered to the
different parts of your identity then
when you find the ones for you
be active be active it's okay to you
know be a fly on the wall for a little
bit and just see
how things are going and everything but
be active
introduce yourself say hey i'm naya i am
new to this and i'm really hoping to
learn more about xyz
any help y'all could provide or any
resources y'all could recommend would be
really appreciated
but no introduce yourself and then just
see how communication goes with
different people
and all of this but now make sure you're
active
make sure you're asking questions when
you have questions about you're learning
about
leak code problems about interviews ask
those questions
and also make sure you're staying up to
date with this group so that you're not
only active when you have a question
but you're also making sure you're
putting in your two cents
when other people have questions because
that's not cool y'all people who are
just takers i've said this in different
videos
don't take take take like make sure we
are building mutual
mutually beneficial relationships and as
you are active in these groups
if you see people that you would like to
learn more about
simply just ask me like hey i would love
to speak with some of y'all about how
you got to where you are today
if you are free please let me know i
would like a 20 to 30 minute call
now that being said with facebook groups
there are groups for learning
and then there are groups for just the
dev
world in general so if you're in a
strictly learning group
like 100 days of code i think that's
what it is 100 days of code
or something like that that may not be
the best place to go
for asking for advice and insights
because everyone around you is in the
same place as you do you see what i'm
saying
if everyone is learning html and css no
one can really tell you how they got to
their spot at google because no one's
there yet
so make sure you also are keeping in
mind who your audience
is oh and let me just say don't get so
caught up on the word
mentor you don't need to ask hey can you
be my mentor you don't need
that don't get so caught up on the ward
and get
more focused on the relationship because
the word means nothing to be completely
honest the word
doesn't mean much unless you're part of
an actual
mentoring program that is what it
has defined itself as other than that
don't get
so caught up on the word and really
think about the relationships
because people can also kind of get a
little bit
more hesitant to assist if you ask can
you be my mentor because
they may think they're not in the place
they would like to be
to help to to be that for somebody
and yet if you had an ass they would
have been able to provide you all these
resources
so don't get so caught up on the word
i'm just using this word because
that is really kind of the role that
they would be
but that doesn't mean you have to ask
you have to say mentor but no keep on
with this pattern of
talking to people reaching out to them
having calls and
it's it can be an exhausting process it
can be very time consuming but honestly
that's how you get the best results
basically
that's how where when it's time for you
to start looking for a job
people will feel more comfortable
referring you to a job where people will
feel
more comfortable saying hey we actually
just got a
opening how about you apply so don't say
to yourself oh i'll start looking for
mentor when i start looking for a job
no it's best to start this as soon as
possible
because that way when it's time that you
really need
something like a job you have already
cultivated
these robust relationships with people
and that's why i say this is not a one
week process or whatever this
this takes time but can end up so
rewarding afterwards because now
once you get the job you still would
want somebody to
kind of assist you into that transition
of going from learning to code
to being a developer yourself and
how should i do this how should i talk
to managers how should i
do x y and z and so having someone more
experienced than you
kind of show you the ropes whether or
not they are
part of the company you just got hired
for it helps
a lot especially because in software
engineering
people move around a lot people hop from
place to place
and so in a couple of months in a year
and two years
you need a new job you have all these
allies on your side
who would be willing to help you lift
you from where you are
and take you to this new place so that's
why it's so important to find a mentor
find
somebody anyway i hope this helped let
me know if it did let me know what
questions you have
down below in the comments like and
subscribe and i will see you all
later bye